want to get back
oh boy welcome everybody back to the
interval it has been a very very long
time please give yourself a round of
applause for actually showing up
um this is our first
kind of real live talk uh back here at
the interval in in a few years and so
thank you and and this has also been a
talk that i've been talking with creon
about doing for a very very long time
and unfortunately the problem of space
debris has not gotten better
since we started talking about this it's
one of those issues
like asteroid impacts like climate
change that um
that we all face as as a civilization
and i think it's it's one of those
things that
potentially we don't give the right do
as we as we think on a civilizational
scale
uh okay i worked at nasa for decades and
for the last few years i spent a lot of
time on the space debris problem i'll
talk about why shortly
this is uh
my hand and this is a experiment that
was run at the
nasa johnson space flight center space
debris divisions hypervelocity impact
facility and
what we see here is an aluminum plate
that has been impacted at orbital
velocities by a small steel bb
this is what can happen at those
velocities with collisions with even
small objects this is a slightly
larger experiment this is a satellite
mock-up this is a typical you know
small space vehicle maybe a meter in
length
maybe a little longer and this was
hypervelocity impact
with a one centimeter marble sized
aluminum sphere moving at
the relative velocity that your average
space collision in earth orbit might
happen and then on the right is the
resulting fragments that they
reassembled after the
collision with the one
marble-sized object so
small small objects can make a a big
mess i got drawn into this because when
the iridium satellite which is a
communication satellite which there are
many in orbit collided with a
defunct uh russian
cosmos satellite i forget what its
purpose was but
we don't really know what happened in
fact the collision wasn't even predicted
interestingly enough even with all the
tracking of space objects that have been
done in 2009 they collided and a big
debris cloud was tracked but as near as
we can tell this is probably what
happened in the collision was the um
iridium just nicked this like boom that
was sticking out of the cosmos cosmos is
the left-hand one and then this cloud of
particles came about this was a
simulation done by lawrence livermore
labs trying to sort of
retrodict what actually happened there
and this was thousands of fragments
thousands of trackable sized fragments
and of course every one of these
fragments can potentially then collide
with something else and make more
fragments now this fortunately has been
relatively rare the gravity gravity
movie was was showing a dramatization of
something happening at the international
space station and this is a big concern
like we really don't want anything even
remotely like that we don't even want
anything to happen to the international
space station we don't even want a
little tiny hole in it although
we'll talk more about that in a minute
it's it's truly an international project
in fact one might argue that you know
one of the reasons the us and russia
don't go to war is because
there's u.s and russian astronauts up on
the space station at all times and it's
sort of a soft power kind of detent
diplomacy
stabilization process politically but
technologically it's an astonishing
thing it's there have been some debris
strikes on the international space
station that we know about
uh here's
the canadians have made big
contributions to robotics on the space
station and so uh
unfortunately one of their robots has
been damaged by a debris strike again
this is probably only like
maybe a few millimeters in size the
object that made that hole we don't know
there's this beautiful thing on the
international space station called the
coppola which is this sort of
picture
window dome thing where you can it has
no real purpose other than people
looking through it and taking pictures
to it and taking pictures of it and they
lie there and they look down at the
earth in this panoramic view
and it's very beautiful thing it's great
that they made it
but what a lot of people don't know is
on the outside of it there are these
shields that can be folded up actually
every time that they know that there's a
substantial sized piece of debris and by
substantial i mean anything we can track
and by anything we can track in low
earth orbit i mean anything that's about
five centimeters in size or bigger when
they know that there's something five
centimeters in size or bigger that is um
has a conjunction probability of more
than i don't know one in ten thousand
with the space station they close these
shields and they
actually get ready in the various
human capable vehicles that are on the
space station to evacuate
if a catastrophe happens here's some
little tiny thing that hit one of the
windows of the coppolo didn't break it
but you know
all kinds of things up there this is a
solar array
from the hubble space telescope
that was um
retrieved after nine years in orbit and
brought back to earth
this is definitely debris strikes
i don't know the size of these solar
cells we're looking at they're probably
at least like
five by ten centimeters each of those
things may be bigger
this drawing on the chalkboard also
shown here
is from the original paper in 1978
by don kessler and his associates he was
the man who essentially invented
this field or started thinking about the
problem of space debris and he started
thinking about it in the 70s and there
had been no known space collisions at
that time
he was just thinking you know what if we
keep launching stuff into space and you
know occasionally stuff blows up and
occasionally pieces come off and
there's going to be a probability that
things could collide over time and
create more pieces and the idea is that
if debris collisions produce more debris
and produce more debris at a higher rate
than it can be naturally removed or
removed by humans
then
you can end up with just a an impassable
cloud
around the earth and you can just not be
able to launch anything into space maybe
for
thousands of years even so the kessler
syndrome is the idea that there's this
runaway chain reaction and and it just
becomes i don't want to say
uninhabitable but but sort of on space
becomes unusable at least in near
near the earth he made this graph
showing predicted cumulative numbers of
collisions based on different
assumptions about how many or how many
objects were launched each year now i
should point out that it's now the 2020s
and we're launching
many thousands of objects per year not
just
a thousand or so like it's shown here
i went and i
the nasa johnson space center has a
whole debris office with like dozens of
people in it who study this
professionally for their whole careers
and they publish a newsletter i think
quarterly and one of the things the
newsletter has in addition to research
is um
it has
discussions about various events
that happen in orbit and some are called
collisions
and that's where they're pretty sure
based on the tracking that something
collided and other types of events are
called fragmentations
and fragmentations can happen for many
reasons
uh
one reason is something can explode like
a fuel tank can get weakened if it's not
empty and it's still pressurized and
it's in orbit for a long time in and out
of the sun
it can just crack
and fragment and explode batteries can
explode
unexplained fragmentations could be
collisions with objects that are too
small to be tracked
and unexplained fragmentations could
even be anti-satellite weapons
possibly
so what i did was i took this original
figure from this original paper by
kessler from 78
and i looked in all these reports from
the johnson space center talking about
the different events
that have happened collision events
fragmentation events and i overlaid the
cumulative number
of events
on kessler's graphs
so in the solid orange circles are the
collisions and each time there's a
collision that it goes up
one more count
and these hollow
orange circles are the collisions plus
the unexplained fragmentation events so
what we see rather interestingly and the
the upper right
hollow orange circle is literally off
the chart um i mean it's a little bit
off the chart and uh what we see is that
it's tracking his predictions rather
well
as i said uh jsc you know here we just
see in 2020 they cataloged
five breakup events um i don't know if
they classified them as collisions or
just breakups fragmentations i think
these might have been all fragmentations
you can see some of these things that
say satellite name are actually
satellites and some of them are our
third stages or tanks or covers and
various
large pieces of junk that are up there
now here's a graph that shows this is
again from jsc
it shows the total number of objects in
space since the dawn of the space age
and uh they're classified by by
different types as you can see the most
important one is the total objects
because when you're thinking about
collisions that's kind of what matters
and you'll see that there's those step
functions in there like the thing
labeled one
and two and three
and uh
one of those is the iridium cosmos
collision i mentioned that number one
the thing that kind of drew me and a
bunch of other people into this field it
was not the first collision
we don't think but it was the first one
that produced a lot of debris and then
two and three were anti-satellite tests
respectively uh
chinese and russian
and as you may know the us recently
announced a unilateral ban on
anti-satellite weapons testing hopefully
the rest of the world will fall suit
because that's one of the most important
things we could do both for world
stability and keeping the orbital
environment safer in terms of debris
uh when i remember i said there's this
we can track down to about five
centimeters but we have done experiments
where we point high-powered radars
they're called beam park experiments
because you park the radar beam and you
just point it at one spot and as
stuff
go
goes
in orbit you get these radar reflections
so by taking a narrow really high power
pencil radar beam
and what and seeing what comes back you
can get range and cross-section
and get statistics on what's up there
you can't survey the whole sky this way
but you can kind of get the fluxes and
make assumptions that they're uniform
perhaps
and what we see here it's a log log plot
you can see that the number of objects
of smaller size if you go to ten times
smaller objects there's like roughly ten
times as many objects so it's a simple
power law there are
thousand times as much flux of
millimeter-sized objects as there is
of say
you know
larger objects this is just saying that
there's a lot of small stuff up there
that we're not tracking and that small
stuff as we saw from the beginning could
be kind of dangerous
um interestingly enough these are not
distributed equally
in
space there are certain
orbital altitudes that are much more
congested
you can see up about 850 kilometers
there's a lot of congestion
at these lower altitudes
though it's kind of lucky one nice thing
about really low altitudes like down
below 500 is that stuff just doesn't
stay up very long
atmospheric drag slows it down and as it
slows it down the orbit gets even lower
and then the atmospheric drag gets even
higher kind of gets exponentially higher
as you go lower and pretty soon
when you're down at um
you know 400 kilometers
you don't have long to live no matter
unless you're very dense and heavy like
if we took that tungsten ball you know
it might live a long time but but most
satellites are debris is going to a very
short time what do we what can we do to
reduce
this problem and ensure that we can
continue going into space and don't face
like a debris minefield that's
impassable
full of satellites and
nuts and bolts and other junk well
stop producing debris it's the first
things i should point out that the rules
have gotten a lot more
draconian
both the us rules and the un rules and
like it used to be that you know you
could like
have a lens cap go flying off of your
telescope and nobody cared and you could
have you know
explosive bolts send fragments
everywhere when you were separating the
rocket stage
and now all that stuff is uh
not allowed at all and all but the most
pariah nations abide by these
conventions you have to go through a
whole bunch of things to show that
you're not going to be producing debris
that stuff's going to fall off your
spacecraft that stuff's not going to
explode
we have to stop doing anti-satellite
weapons tests because in a sense they're
like designed to produce debris and um
it's probably not a good idea
another thing we can do is you know we
can just slow down launching stuff and
wait and wait for the atmosphere to
clean stuff out and that as i said works
at lower altitudes but unfortunately at
the higher altitudes you know a thousand
kilometers and above that stuff is going
to be up there for hundreds or even
thousands of years and when you get up
into like geo
and the higher orbits
they're going to be there
basically forever from our point of view
even from the long now's point of view
you know like millions of years right
another thing that helps us is uh
the solar cycle so the solar the sun has
like this seven-year cycle or 14-year
cycle depending on how you want to look
at it
and it gets active and it gets inactive
and it gets active and it gets inactive
and when it gets active
it it puts out a lot more radiation at
certain wavelengths and they don't
matter so much to us down here
hard to detect on the surface of the
earth but in the very upper atmosphere
uh solar activity particularly solar
flares those solar
excursions
make big changes in the extreme upper
atmospheric density they can change the
temperature of the upper atmosphere and
hence the density like they puff up the
atmosphere of the earth and it gets way
denser
at like
two three four five hundred kilometers
even
above the surface of the earth when the
sun gets active and that makes stuff get
dragged down much faster because if
there's more atmospheric density it gets
slowed down and then it slows down more
and then it gets denser
the lower atmosphere and it burns up
this is the solar cycle and the debris
re-entries kind of super posed with each
other so when the sun is active the red
curve
more debris re-enters so that's you know
there's some cleaning that's going on
naturally but but not enough
so
another thing we
do
is we restrict the lifetime of
satellites
meaning so we don't want a bunch of dead
satellites up there there are already
too many and we really don't want dead
satellites up there so what does that
mean
well you can never ensure that a
satellite won't die and just remain in
orbit as a basically a big piece of junk
but what you can do is you can
say you have to dispose of it after a
certain number of years if it's still
alive so you have to have an engine on
it with enough propellant
to take it
and re-enter into the earth's atmosphere
or at the very least put it into an
orbit that nobody cares about so those
are disposal options another thing you
can do is just fly it very low to begin
with and then you know it's going to
have a very short lifetime
even if it dies
that's what we do at planet labs mostly
as we
build
satellites we launch them into
relatively low orbits they're only
designed to last say five years because
after five years the technology's
presumably much better and we don't
really want them anymore so we just have
them
at a low enough orbit that after about
five years they re-enter and burn up but
that's not always been the case if
you're building a billion dollar
satellite you might want it to last a
lot longer than five years and
therefore you you have to be very
careful and have some way to dispose of
it and unfortunately
the world's largest piece of space junk
right now is a billion dollar satellite
called nvsat that the european space
european space agency sent up there it's
about the size of a school bus and it
died
and it's totally dead i mean it's and
it's just
it's up there and
these very large dead objects are in a
sense the biggest threat because if
something collides with them
they can make a huge mess
there's a lot of proposals also for
going up and getting stuff out of it
that's called active debris removal
so
the first thing that you can avoid you
do to sort of avoid collisions at least
for active satellites is have a traffic
management system kind of like we do
with air traffic management and you want
you want the satellites to you want
everybody to know where all the
satellites are and you want everything
in an orderly pattern so that collisions
are very unlikely this would be a
typical
distribution of satellites in a big
constellation like maybe starlink or
oneweb or something like that i mean
this is simplified but a lot of
satellites in a lot of different orbits
and it might look like a giant mess and
how could you
uh ever
you know how could you hope to not have
a collision with a constellation this
dense
but the the issue is that if you look at
it in a three-dimensional geometry you
can see that there's ways to kind of
thread stuff through each other
um you can imagine
this thing sort of fully populated with
these orange dots like there could be
thousands and thousands of them up there
and if they're all choreographed just
right they can sort of do a dance and
one way to understand the dance is to
map it out in in other coordinate
systems so that you know like instead of
latitude and longitude on the earth you
can kind of map it out in these grids
and tauruses where you're using
different mathematical functions and
then they turn into these regular square
patterns and in a sense every satellite
is just sitting in a box now when you
put it back onto the three dimensions of
the sphere of the earth
it doesn't look like a box so much
anymore so here's here's the starlink
constellation and this is we're mapping
it out not in latitude and longitude or
not in altitude and inclination or any
of the standard orbital elements and
what we see here is a bunch of starlink
satellites and the ones that are in
their assigned orbits are these pale
gray dots and then this the brightly
colored ones are the ones that have been
recently launched so the ones that have
recently been launched are the ones that
are moving and once they get into their
assigned positions they turn they turn
gray
each different launch is a different
color
and you can see as they get gray they
just drop onto this grid
and this this means that even though
they're all orbit around the earth in
this complicated dance in their in this
special coordinate system they're just
lying on a grid
uh the diamond shaped ones are defunct
some of those defunct ones they're
really defunct like they have no control
over them anymore
um but the point is that you can see
these gray ones on the right slowing
down and now they're locked into their
position and now we're going to watch
these blue
ones they slow down and they lock into
their position and turn gray and you can
see that they're slowly building up this
grid and and then when you have this
grid if everybody stays in their box
once it's just a rigid grid and they're
all up there and everybody stays in
their little box there's not going to be
any collisions in that constellation and
so we could have boxes like that
globally you know for the entire world
satellites actually and we can have lots
of satellites up there if everybody
stays in their box
um of course this is complicated by the
fact that you've got debris objects
streaming through here who don't know
about the boxes right
but
it's a start
so what do we do about these debris
objects so we can do active debris
removal
you know everybody's got their favorite
idea or we're going to build with the
robot with claws and it's going to grab
stuff and then bring it back to earth or
we're going to like this is an actual uh
an actual
satellite servicing mission but
satellite servicing and debris removal
are very similar you have to get into
proximity of another satellite you have
to
grab grab it you have to attach to it
and then you have to do something either
refuel it or bring it
or bring it back to the atmosphere so it
can burn up or move it to some graveyard
orbit but this is very similar to what
you'd have to do
if you were trying to bring a dead
satellite back
now the problem is oftentimes debris
objects and dead objects they're
tumbling
makes it harder to
get a hold of them so
of course people have said oh well we'll
just inflate like giant balloons and you
know we'll like we'll like
somehow stick it to a balloon or or
maybe or everyone thinks they're very
clever why don't you just send up a net
and
the thing to remember about this is
these are objects in orbit and if you do
this if you get something wrong you end
up just creating more debris like you
can imagine this net gets tangled up and
then you know now you've got an even
worse problem right and now you've got
an even bigger thing flying around there
or something accidentally
it gets tangled up and it hits something
else i mean these and also by the way
all these kind of schemes like this they
also are like anti-satellite weapons in
disguise because i could just as well
use this to go take your satellite and
and and remove it or to cover it up or
turn it off as i could to get out of
take a piece of space junk out of orbit
uh you know if there's something
something is tumbling you have to get
you have to
i don't know where people come up with
these ideas but
i just collected as many as i could
uh you know we're going to catch it with
harpoons
um
and then drag it away
now this is actually this is a this was
a european space mission that got pretty
far along the planning phase called e.d
orbit this thing on the right is that
school bus sized
gigantic envy sat dead
environmental satellite and then the
thing on the left was going it was fully
all designed and ready to go well it
wasn't built yet and it was going to
grab the envy sat which was not tumbling
i don't believe and attach itself to the
envy set and then just de-boost the
whole thing down into the atmosphere and
that got cancelled unfortunately so
that's envy set is still up there
but they are actually launched this is
going to launch in 2025. this is called
clear space the thing on the left is is
getting this
medium-sized piece of junk that's known
to be up there and um
uh you're spending 86 million euros on
this mission to bring back this one
piece of junk
so you can imagine a scenario where you
remove the n largest pieces of junk from
orbit every year
and so the question is if you and since
the largest pieces of junk are in a
sense the biggest threat because they'll
produce the most additional junk if they
get impacted you might say well what
would this have what effect would this
have on the overall growth of the debris
population if we removed the n largest
pieces from orbit so since we have good
information about much of what's up
there
and um
and a lot of historical data here we can
see
various growth scenarios for space
debris this is assuming no additional
anti-satellite weapons tests okay but
this says
if you just do business as usual you get
the thick black line
that's going up into the right highest
one
and that's just using like
debris radiation techniques and then if
you use um
if you really if you
add in adro2 which is active debris
removal of the two largest objects the
two most dangerous objects per year
then you obviously get the dotted line
which is far less growth and if you go
to adr5
that's the line that's almost flat
going into the future and that's if you
remove the five
worst offenders every year
so and then those the waviness of those
lines is that solar cycle that i was
talking about so more stuff is going up
there all the time but more stuff is
being cleaned out all the time and you
can balance it out
and then if you do a little active
debris removal of just five objects per
year you can flatten this out
so that's kind of that's pretty good
news
why not just descend a giant laser up
there and blast it and vaporize it
and it's like
yes that was called star wars that was
like
that's called space weapons and that is
arguably
i mean if you have megawatt class lasers
in space
oh they're just up there to sell you
know mitigate debris
this is going to be a hard sell ming the
merciless was the only one who was
capable of building such lasers as i
understand it
ahead of his time exactly um
and uh that's the thing these things are
also
weapons
some colleagues and i at nasa came up
with a thing we called light force
uh which was a way to use relatively low
power lasers
to do space collision avoidance not to
blast things out of the sky or vaporize
them
this is work that will marshall and i
did back at nasa and as well as a number
of others whose names i shall
mention later and the idea was you use a
ground-based laser hooked up to a
moderate-sized telescope
shown here in the center
and
your let's say you're tracking a piece
of debris
that can't maneuver on its own and you
have a prediction that it's going to
collide with another piece of debris
that can't maneuver on its own now these
are the kind of in a way the worst
problems because first of all there's
arguably more debris than there is
uh non-debris up there and the second is
that debris in general you know debris
can't maneuver so there's no chance of
somebody moving out of the way under
their own power so the question is how
do you prevent debris debris collisions
and the idea is if you shine this laser
through this telescope on a piece of
debris
you're not going to vaporize it or
anything like that you're going to put a
little bit of what's called radiation
pressure on it the kind of thing that
spins those little
solar spinny things in those evacuated
bulbs and
radiation pressure is a thing it
actually you have to take the sun's
radiation pressure into account when
you're calculating the trajectory of a
satellite in orbit it's a slight
perturbing force in addition to gravity
and atmospheric drag so radiation
pressure is a thing and it turns out
that by using one of these industrial 10
kilowatt class lasers and a telescope of
moderate aperture like a university
class telescope like a one meter
aperture telescope
using a laser in that telescope and some
additional hardware you can put enough
light energy on a piece of debris that
is equivalent to about what it would see
in the sun but you can
put it either to slow it down in its
orbit or to speed it up in its orbit if
you point it in the right direction at
the right time and you can perturb the
trajectory of that object that's what's
shown here on the upper right of this
diagram is like
the unperturbed trajectory without the
laser engagement and the perturbed
trajectory with the laser engagement you
only impart
a few millimeters per second of delta v
with each of these engagements but it
turns out a few millimeters per second
over the course of a few hours or days
amounts to
a lot of distance that you can perturb
the end uh
position of this object and so you can
actually uh avoid collisions this way
the question is you know how
how how well does this actually work
what do the numbers actually say how
much is it going to cost so we made this
proposal
a whole bunch of organizations teamed up
here's the picture of
one of these lasers it's about i don't
know how much these things cost
some fraction of a million dollars i
think maybe less now 10 kilowatts that's
about the size of a large fridge here's
a one meter class telescope that's also
about a million bucks maybe a little
less and here's a high power adaptive
optic system that's another thing you
need for this
and then if you combine this stuff
together this is showing like one piece
of debris it'll make passes over this
laser and sometimes you'll be able to
engage it for a short time and sometimes
you'll be able to engage it for a long
time and maybe since it's orbiting the
earth like roughly every 90 minutes most
definitely
with orbit is orbiting every 90 minutes
you would engage for maybe
uh 16 illuminations over the course of
24 hours some of them longer some of
them are shorter and you could end up
perturbing the position of this object
by engaging with the laser and just
giving it gentle little pushes uh you
could perturb it enough that
down the line you've you've altered its
trajectory by hundreds or even thousands
of meters that's shown here the
perturbed versus unperturbed trajectory
and this is with actual physics in the
model okay it turns out the our
australian colleagues then actually went
and kind of did this they at least
demoed it they had the laser they had
the telescope
and they
they did some demos of this so this was
we did experiments at the starfire
optical range here they are actually
prototyping it on their optical mesh
this is the high power adaptive optics
thing
that's the technicality but because of
the atmosphere you have to have some
fancy corrective optics
and uh
there's the australian facility
mount stromlo wonderful people
so this works i'm gonna last last thing
i'm gonna talk about is um
a debris mediation scheme by george
sarver from nasa ames this is brilliant
he came up with this thing let's say you
have like one of those swarms like you
saw in the movie the gravity movie or
like there's like
a thousand nuts and bolts and little
things all come in you know because
maybe something fragmented and it's like
a it's sort of a jet anyway i was like
well how could you possibly remove
debris like that like you're not gonna
you know do that with harpoons right so
his scheme is you launch a rocket which
is basically carrying a payload that's
just a big tank of of liquid carbon
dioxide anyway you launch this thing
into a retrograde orbit meaning the
opposite orbit if you have this cloud of
debris particles coming you launch this
tank of co2 so that it's going to
intersect this cloud and you make it
time it so that's going to intersect it
on the night side of the earth
and then just in time
the co2 tank vents all of its co2
which goes from liquid phase
to quickly to gas and then it turns into
crystals dry ice crystals and so on the
night side of the earth so these dry ice
crystals just sit there imagine like
this long contrail of dry ice crystals
that's been precision laid out so that
the debris cloud is going to pass right
through it
and then the debris cloud and then the
the rocket kind of re-enters itself
using its own jets of co2 leaves this
debris cloud contrail right in the path
of the oncoming debris and the oncoming
debris comes and it just gets ablated by
this cloud of dry ass crystals
all the nuts and bolts and everything
slowed down
burned up
and then what happens
20 minutes later the earth rotates and
all this is in the day side and the
crystals just sublime
and
instantly dissipate
because they turn back into gas which
expands immediately
so i thought that's a brilliant scheme
maybe we'll do that someday
real practical ones
i think i'm going to end it there
thanks very much
[Applause]
so thank you i want to
i really appreciate that you actually
showed a hopeful view of space debris in
this talk which is very rare that we get
to see and when i visited you guys in
south america there's like maybe a
couple of your
places your offices go but it was kind
of stunning to me after going to a nasa
launch and then showing up at planet
there was you know you guys were
tracking at that time hundreds of
satellites from
one screen in south of market um and
then going to you know nasa where
they're like hundreds of people tracking
one thing um but that that kind of
difference that's happening in the um
now that we have
uh
so many private efforts how do they
you mentioned this coordination thing
how how is the coordination happening
both between international
secret things of military and
less secret things in the private world
um
yeah that was a lot of stuff in there um
so let's let's talk about first is there
one database how does how does it work
uh there's
there's essentially one database
no even that's complicated but everybody
knows it's kind of like asking is there
one um
search engine you know what i mean like
there's several of them and most
professionals know how to use multiple
ones and that's not a huge issue
and there's ways to combine them to get
higher accuracy
fusion and all that stuff i want to give
some credit to nasa and these kind of
places look when i love planet labs but
when we have hundreds of when we have
hundreds of satellites controlled by one
person these are like basically simple
little webcams in space with some radios
on board when nasa has hundreds of
people controlling something it's like
the space station or a mars rover or
something like this it's like a whole
other level of complexity and risk
i mean if one of our if one of our
satellites goes out it's no huge deal if
if one of those mars rovers goes out
it's like hundreds of careers and and
and you know billions of dollars so
there's a reason that they we do things
differently
uh
i have the highest respect for nasa in
many ways in spite of my snarky comments
earlier and one of the things that i
don't think we talked about you kind of
showed it at the beginning but like what
are the what are the velocities that we
are talking about thank you so much
average average average low earth orbit
collision velocity is uh
many kilometers per second uh
in miles per hour
uh
tens of thousands of miles i mean it's
like 10 times faster than a rifle bullet
in general so hyper velocity like
hypersonic
and you mentioned one of those
unpredicted uh collisions that happened
with the uh
canada arm um
and a few of those like how many of
those are we now seeing per year
well
again to see it we have to either have
astronauts up there noticing that
there's a hole or there wasn't one
before or we have to see some event with
the radar on earth and that means it's
got to have big
big fragments so we're only seeing right
now
as i said at fragmentations like
from zero to
three or four a year
maybe five and
but
we don't really know this micro
fragmentations could be happening more
frequently
and we have a question from the
internets and we're gonna grab some
questions here from the audience next as
well
um
is there is there a current curve that's
petting us towards a kessler syndrome
that
if you if if left alone where would we
where would we be
uh if left alone like if we stopped i
mean you showed a curve that was going
up
that we were hoping to flatten right of
space debris at what point does that
curve hit kessler
oh well don't forget that curve when i
plotted those points on top of kessler's
thing i mean we were talking about over
the course of many decades an aggregate
of like 12 collisions so we're not in
like any sort of
a horrible situation right now um
you'd have to extrapolate those curves
much farther to have a real
impenetrable
wall of space debris in orbit around the
earth
the curves which showed those growth
scenarios that were actually coming from
the nasa debris office that show a more
linear
growth scenario
that's i think more like what's in our
near future and the question is are we
just going to let it get worse and worse
or are we going to flatten it out it's
not that much work to flatten it out uh
is it going to go non-linear it depends
on your kind of it depends on your time
scale like almost almost any curve is
linear
if you zoom in far enough
yes
all right do we have any questions uh
short uh questions
charles
let me repeat that just since we don't
have a mic out there so given what's up
there right now what is the chances of a
big nasty collision we've already had
two that were maybe planned or were like
the chinese one and the russian one but
something on the order of the gravity
kind of collision
this is very hard because this is kind
of one of these
low probability high impact
events
it's like a poisson process so you know
it
it's like
if
i don't know how to answer that the
gravity thing was
exaggerated and it wouldn't really go
like that but like what's the
probability of a big object smashing
into the space station that's very low
because we know where the big objects
are and we know where the space station
is and we're going to move the space
station out of the way
okay
but um
but
that iridium cosmos collision that kind
of drugged me into this which produced
thousands of fragments
many of which are re-entered by now but
um
yeah i think we can expect to see
every few years
something like that may be bigger it's
on process so sometimes
a lot of them come and then there's a
big gap
fair enough other questions
follow
so the question is could you use
any of these systems like the what the
laser system you mentioned um
effectively to push something into a
correlated orbit
and if it did happen would anybody be
able to detect that it was happening
i think the answer is it would be very
hard and you could detect it and it
doesn't really matter because
how would you even know if someone was
nudging this debris
or if it was just that was how it was
headed i mean what i'm saying is that
you'd see that there's a collision
probability and it's getting worse as
time goes on and so you'd make a
maneuver
and if you're just trying to make debris
collide with other debris that's just
terrorism that's that like you're not
taking out anyone's asset there you're
just making a mess
right other questions
yeah are the graphs including the
particles that are too small to be
tracked
is that what you're asking
so they could have probabilities but
we're not tracking them is that what
you're asking yeah
some of the graphs showed
particles
that are
smaller
than the ones that are tracked because
we do know something about what's up
there of even a very small size like
like that's one of the reasons they
brought back those panels from the
hubble space telescope it's like well
those things have been up there for nine
years and you know they're gonna have
nine years worth of bombardment and then
you can go look and see how many holes
of given size there are and you can at
least know
roughly the statistics of what's up
there and how dangerous it is obviously
you're not tracking every single sand
grain or bb in orbit not yet we could
make radars that might be able to do
that but um
so it's kind of a mixed bag we know
something about
the statistics and distributions of the
smaller objects and something about how
dangerous they are but we certainly
don't know where everyone is at all
times
all right so i'm going to wrap this up
and people we're going to stay here and
people can ask more questions but i want
to kind of bring this back to that
original kind of question of threat
models that we all have to hold in our
heads um these days um is this question
of you know where does this fit in your
head in the world of something like
climate change or an asteroid impact or
some other kind of existential threat
like how do you put this into your
yeah well okay
i'll end on a
controversial note climate change is not
an existential threat
it's not an existential to the threat to
the planet or even to humans it it could
be a serious
problem that could set our civilization
back
maybe
irrevocably back even i mean so could
the kessler syndrome it could lock us
here on earth there are similarities
i mean and and then neither is the
kessler syndrome an existential threat
like the worst it's going to do is you
know keep us from going into space for a
thousand years okay we would last a long
time without ever going into space
okay um
but i'd like to
and i asteroid impacts i don't
that's too far
that's too different i think that
there's great similarities and great
differences between the space debris
problem and the climate problem and i'd
like to focus
uh they both seem similar because
they're like global environmental
problems and it's a coordination problem
because you have to try and get
everybody to do something and it's going
to be very it's going to be somewhat
expensive
in the case of space debris and
horrifically expensive in the case of
uh
carbon emissions at least that part of
climate change to
mitigate in the standard stupid ways
that they want to mitigate it
i should be careful what i say but uh
but
there are similar problems in this way
they are from the sky
they're like
involving the whole earth
but they're also very different problems
climate change and
space debris i mean space debris is a
simple problem first of all there's no
question about are humans contributing
to it or not like okay
um
secondly and how much are they there's
no non-progenic problem right exactly
there's no it's all anthropogenic space
debris pretty much and uh then there's
um
and then there's the uh the issue of
like how good are the models well like
people argue about these climate models
all the time it's it's like
so hard i would i'd venture it's almost
impossible it's not my field but it's
like i've done fluid dynamics and i've
done chemistry and i can tell you we
can't even do
tiny little
airplanes and simple molecules very
accurately and the idea we're going to
model the whole planet with the sun and
the magnetosphere and the biosphere and
the oceans and make predictions down to
a fraction of degrees celsius over the
course of decades i find that
preposterous and
and contrast that with space debris it's
like newtonian orbits and collision
statistics there's really no
not much to argue about right everyone
it's like the models are pretty simple
you can run them on a laptop
well i like coming out of here thinking
that space debris is less of a problem
that i went going in so thank you for
that
[Applause]
[Music]
you